I want to add one super fast
addendum to the video on
Friedel-Crafts acylation.
In the last step of the
mechanism I had this chlorine
swipe the electron, or
essentially that electron that
was with the aluminum.
It was given to the
hydrogen proton.
So the hydrogen was
nabbed away.
Its electron was allowed to go
back into the benzene ring.
So the aluminum lost
a chlorine.
This benzene ring
lost a proton.
It was able to take back
that electron.
And I forgot to draw the
hydrogen and the chlorine.
So then that results in
hydrogen chloride.
So you have the hydrogen proton
bonded-- it took this
electron from the aluminum--
and it is
bonded to the chlorine.
I didn't want to forget that
in that last step of the
Friedel-Crafts acylation.
We also get some hydrogen
chloride.